everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're going to be
going over game newman of four for the
2013 World Chess Championship between an
on the reigning champion and Magnus
Carlsen the highest rated chess player
in the world in this particular game
game number four anons gonna be playing
the white pieces Magnus Carlsen is gonna
be defending with the black pieces it up
into this point so if you've been
keeping up with the series we are tied
at three draws to three draws each game
has gotten a little bit more exciting
the first two were probably some of the
most boring games I've ever seen only
lasted 16 and 20 something moves
respectively the last game was actually
pretty exciting although it didn't end
up going to a draw this game is actually
the longest game that we've had so
definitely get to actually see some
chess going on so we'll go ahead and get
into it
anon starts with Pawnee form and then
after a five we get into the Rye Lopez
which one of the more common openings
after this pawn here to e4 a lot of
different ways that Magnus Carlsen can
respond decides to go for the Berlin
defense something that Garry Kasparov
used to play quite a bit you know
obviously Magnus Carlsen and Garry
Kasparov have trained a lot together
you know once Garry Kasparov actually
you know hung it up and kind of retired
he actually took Magnus Carlsen under
his wing and trained him up a bit
my guess is that at some point in that
training the Berlin defense came up
because again Kasparov used it kind of
at the high stage so Magnus Carlsen like
he has been the entire tournament was
playing extremely quickly at the
beginning of the game his opening book
where a lot of the moves are memorized
didn't have to think about too much at
all so went into the Berlin defense
after Castle decides to go ahead and
take this pawn here on e4 anon doesn't
even try to right away combat this and
plays this pawn to d4 Magnus Carlsen
decides not to go ahead and try to hold
on to it it can be very dangerous and
cumbersome to try to hold on to this
pawn advantage so he decides to just
come back here to Knight to d6 and then
after the bishop takes and we have the
exchange then you
see both sides are now equal in material
so the cents gonna come back here to f5
again not really any great square to
take this and why it decided to go ahead
and exchange here
the Queen's come off the board so black
cannot castle on either side of the
board although depending on how familiar
you are with chess usually that's not
the worst thing ever
if your opponent's queen is off the
board if your opponent's queen is on the
board that's usually when you you really
care more about at least castling on one
side of the board but your King can
usually stay pretty safe even in the
center of the board
if your opponent's queen is off the
board now you still have to you know
watch out for a few things here and
there but as you approach the in game
you actually want your King more
involved into the game more in the
center of the board so we can actually
be a powerful piece in your attack and
so this is definitely not a bad place
for this King to be right now so we now
see an on play a pawn here to h1 and
then we see the bishop come to d7 and
then the rooks kind of swing over here
to d1 kind of pinned down this Bishop
here and then Bishop here to e7 it and
this is definitely a defense that I
don't see very often even studying a lot
of famous events this formation right
here is not seen very often but my guess
is Magnus Carlsen is pretty comfortable
with us and has studied this position
before so from here we see Knight to c3
again getting the rest of the pieces
developed in the game for Don and then
we see the King coming over here to c8
this does somewhat cramp the position
for magnus carlsen you know it's gonna
be a little bit harder for this rook
here on a 8 to get involved into the
action could have tried something
bringing it over to e8 if you wanted to
you know definitely wants to make sure
that his bishops not pinned so he can
move this but this again does cramp him
a little bit now we see the bishop come
here to g5 definitely want to you know
finish up with the development right
here and then we just see that you know
the pawn age six and then both sides
decide to go ahead and trade off their
Bishop here on e7 so you know going into
you know the middle and in game
we see kind of a two-night versus a
bishop and a knight from black now we
see the route come over here to d2 d2 d3
both fine definitely want to go ahead
and there's one open file and that's the
D file you always wanted rooks on an
open file so that's exactly what it nons
going for he's gonna try to double up
his rooks right here and really hone
down on controlling this defy we're
knowing that if he looks his opponent
you know this a8 rook right here he
can't get involved into the action it's
gonna be a few moves and again it's
gonna be you know one too little just to
bring his rook over here to the eight
right now so that's kind of the plan of
attack right now pawn now comes to a c5
wants to get some sort of you know
opening over here so that you know block
and start to maneuver some of his pieces
and then we see the brook swing over to
the one kind as we talked about and then
the bishop comes to e6 recognizing that
okay there there's too many attackers on
the bishop so it wants to make sure he
gets out of the way and kind of brings
it to this nice central square right now
now that the Knights gonna come back
here to e1 and this is where I think a
lot of the the wheels fell off or nod
that this was in my opinion you know
everyone kind of has their opinion this
was the the worst move in the match for
me if you kind of look at it and not
actually has a pretty nice setup right
here both sides are even in material but
if you look at it you know black has you
know doubled pawns here on the C file
white controls the center of the board
he does have the e pawn right here black
doesn't have is a or D pawn white has
both of his rooks dominating this D file
we have the the King right here on c8
that's not doing anything but it's also
cramping the style of the rook on a
eight so again an on he can really start
to put the pressure anytime you have you
know a large lead like this you can
really start to you know play a move
that will force your opponent to do
something so you know from here we could
have seen Knight here to e4 more of a
centralizing you know piece also
attacking this pawn here on c5 this is
definitely much more active instead
again you know this Knights also
protecting this pawn on e5 so when that
moves away it doesn't have that
so he instead decides to bring his
knight down to e1 and then after the
Knight to g6 you know attacking this
pawn here on e5 then the Knights gonna
swing over here to d3 which is now
attacking this pawn on c5 but then all
black has to do is play just pawn here
to b6 and so if we kind of look at it
white has gone from a nice little active
position attacking this pawn all of a
sudden to bringing his knight to a worse
square because now this Knights blocking
both of these rooks here on the 1 and d2
they're definitely not as active as they
used to be and all this just to bring
his knight over so he can attack it and
all Magnus Carlsen had to do is just
play this pawn here to be 6 so
definitely one of the more questionable
moves that I saw in the tournament so
far just because again an on just really
had a huge lead in my opinion and then
just pretty much gave it away in just a
couple moves and after this you know as
White's move and I kind of expected a
nod to kind of regroup and kind of
assess the situation and realize ok you
know we have this pawn right here it is
being protected by this knight on c3 so
you definitely wanna keep this nut here
on c3 you could play something like pawn
to b3 to kind of protect it so now you
can you know play your knight somewhere
else if you wanted to centralize it you
know Knight here to e4 you could always
bring it tonight here to e2 instead
white decides to go ahead and just bring
his Knight to e2 leaving that pawn
hanging in Magnus Carlsen just
immediately just eats it up here on a2
so black goes up in material again we've
gone from an on being up to just a few
moves later in my opinion you know black
is definitely up definitely up in
material and then as far as in the game
itself you know definitely wants to make
sure that he gets this you know rook
involved you know could play King here
to b7 and then get this rook involved
into the game so a few questionable
moves from an odd but an on now plays
pawn to b3 trying to track the bishop
and then this pawn here to see for
recognizing that this is kind of the
only way to safely hold on to this
Bishop and so now the knight takes and
the pawn is going to take
can't take right now just because the
ponds gonna push forward too much
pressure so instead decides to take that
pawn now the bishop is gonna come back
and now it's gonna be able to come back
safely after the knight comes here to c3
than the bishop is gonna swing back here
to f5 so again if we can't look at it if
we assess the situation black has six
pawns to the five pawns from whites
white has two of his knights so he would
really like to keep things on one side
of the board typically as you go towards
the in-game bishops do really well if
there's two sides so you know in this
case there's this pawn chain over here
in this pontine over here because
bishops can get to both sides of the
board very quickly but you know Knights
really prefer to stay on one side of the
board because they can kind of hop
around and if they can just maintain one
side of the board they can just really
dominate where a bishop can't really
dominate just one side of the board so
we'll continue pawn pushes forward to d4
again you don't really have to worry
we're getting towards middle in game
here don't have to worry too much about
the air in front of your King because
you're actually gonna want to get your
King involved into the game so this is
just kind of pushing the bishop back the
bishop comes back here to c8 again no
great squares for this Bishop can't come
here to DC 7 because the rooks you know
can't come here to to e6 because then
this pawn here to f5 would win one of
these pieces so again c8 does give it on
a little breathing room because again it
does block off this rook on a eight and
it's not always about the pieces you
have but it's about the pieces you have
in the fight and this rook on it's not
doing a whole heck of a lot of anything
so the knife now gonna come to d3 again
back here on the first ranks that do
anything so starting to get his pieces
more involved into the game we see pawn
to h5 trying to kind of disrupt these
light squares over here so that he can
get his light squared Bishop and bomb to
the game and now we see pawn here to f5
again kind of forcing the knight to move
and now we see Knight over here to b5
recognizing that okay this is really
gonna be where you know white can start
to put a lot of pressure he does have
these rooks that he can double up on
anything so you know he can swing both
of his works over here and put a lot of
pressure on this pawn on c7 so that's
kind of exactly what white
is just to have this night here and then
start to attack and so now we see the
Pontic and the pawn recapture but this
also does give block the opportunity to
kind of control this long file right
here on the edge file so you can at any
time see this rip swoop down and start
to attack white on the kingside and so
right away we see the root come over to
h4 attacking this pawn right here and
the knight comes back here to f2 you
always want to have your opponent having
their pieces protect and you never want
them to attack so this is exactly you
know where magnus carlsen would like
this Knight it's it's not very active
it's not inserting the board and all its
really doing is protecting this pawn
here on g4 now we see the knight come to
c6 again attacking this pawn here on C
on e6 and then this rook swings over
here to c2 again it would be a mistake
now to go ahead and take this pawn on e5
you know cuz just the rook can swing up
here to c7 this would definitely be bad
so this kind of inadvertently protects
this pawn here on e5 so now we see the
pawn pushed forward to a5 again just
trying to get some some breathing room
over here
you know if the pawns right here and
there's there's a check it could get
pretty awkward you know if the rook
swings over here so this is definitely
gonna be a nice little move to give
blacks some space over here and later on
they may just want to push forward and
you know having your pawns further down
the board is never bad thing so this
rooks gonna swing up to c4 put another
additional defender on this pawn over
here on g4 can also now double up his
rooks and can now also give his knight
involvement to the game if he wants to
so now we see the pawn pushing forward
to g6 again threatening all these light
square pawns is a great way to get this
lights for a bishop involved into the
action so now we see the rook swing over
to c1 and then the bishop coming here to
d7 and then pushing forward and so we're
just gonna have an exchange of pawns
right now and the bishop comes back here
it's a eights and then Knight here to e4
definitely an interesting move and a lot
of the analysts actually you know looked
at this and kind of applauded an on for
you know finding this move you notice
that look I think it's very interesting
obviously this a me
allows block to go ahead and come in
here to do four and I think results
based if you look at it and see Magnus
Carlson's moves you see the King come up
here to f2 and then the rook come to f4
and then the King come up here and
there's no real compensation so the rook
has to swing back here to f8 and then Y
can start to attack over here now black
is up to pawns of material why it's
gonna be able to ring gain one of those
and so again this is a nice central
square for whites but you know if I kind
of come back here and let's say we look
at you know this position right here
after the knight comes to e4
if magnus carlsen takes if the King
comes now to f2 and magnus carlsen
realizes that just swinging up here to
f4 isn't gonna be doing anything right
away and let's say he plays rook here to
d8 it's not as forcing right away but it
you know he still does have this active
rook on g4 and then you could see you
know the King to e3 and then this rook
swing down here to d5 attacking this
night here on b5 both of his rooks are
very active and this particular case you
know black took that pawn and this night
here on e4 doesn't look like the best
move ever now again in the particular
game and actually ended up working
extremely well for Don he did have a
more active knight in the game and
magnus carlsen kind of retreated his
rook back here to f8 so it ended up
being good I don't think it was as good
as some people were saying it was I just
think Magnus Carlsen kind of took the
position and kind of gave it back so in
the particular game again you know
Magnus Carlsen checked and then after
the King moves then the the rook swings
back here and we still have this rook
over on a eight that's not doing
anything at all now what's gonna play
Knight here to d4 again kind of
welcoming the fact that this pawn or
this Knight can take here and then the
rook can swing up here take that pawn
and then take back and so that's exactly
what we see the rooks gonna swing up
here to c7 get one of those pawns back
in material then after the King moves
then this nights gonna take right here
so this particular case you know White
has a much more active position now he
does
have material disadvantage but his
pieces are definitely in the center of
the board and blacks you know while he's
up he's not really doing too much as far
as being super active so so we kind of
play it out starting to get his pieces
involved into the game you know forcing
this this King around the board and the
naans pretty much okay with just
exchanging pieces off the board magnus
carlsen definitely fights for a long
time to see if he can kind of ground
grind down his opponent which he does
many many times tries to find a small
imperfection in the play from his
opponent and he just strikes immediately
unfortunately didn't find that in this
particular game although he does have a
pawn advantage sometimes that's just not
enough it usually ends in a draw up your
opponent plays perfectly which not
actually defended extremely well in this
position so as we kind of come through
both sides just kind of maneuvering
around and then we see the both of the
minor pieces come off the board and then
it's kind of a you know what's gonna
happen with these two pawns and now I'm
going to really like to just go ahead
and you know exchange off these pawns
and then just worry about this one side
of that board he was also really like to
exchange one of these roofs off the
board so he decides to go and play this
pawn to e7 again threatening you know
one more move to promote so that's
something Magnus Carlsen is gonna have
to look at the rest of the game plays
this nice little move of you know rook
over here to g3 still threatening you
know his rook here you know attacking
this pawn here on e7 so you know this
rook can't come over here to g8 and
threaten because now I can just take and
this pawn still protected right here so
that's definitely you know nice little
move now the rooks gonna swing over here
to c3 again and Nan doesn't mind just
exchanging off Magnus Carlsen doesn't
want to do that right away and so it
kind of moves around now we see this
this pawns start to push forward still
maintaining pressure on this efile
because wants to make sure that you know
there isn't something crazy that happens
where you know white can actually get a
queen out of this so again each of the
players move quite a bit more nothing
too crazy this is all just kind of
tactical in games that players go
through in the in the double rook in
game and so as we kind of move through
eventually
side to side okay we're gonna go ahead
and just start exchanging pieces and so
we see the pond take and then we see
after this pond take so we come through
there's exchange right here and in this
position they actually decided to draw
although black is up material as far as
one pond
this is actually an in-game that's going
to end in a draw or stalemate depending
on how you look at it so definitely an
exciting game I think my opinion I'm
gonna go ahead and make you know it
known that I think that Magnus Carlsen
after watching the first four games will
end up winning this tournament I think
he's starting to get into a rhythm I
think watching an on play even after
just four games he's starting to make a
few mistakes I don't know if he's tired
or if he's not as prepared as Magnus
Carlsen but I think after this is a very
long tournament so I think by the end of
this Magnus Carlsen being such a young
guy in really good fitness shape I think
he's just gonna grind down his opponent
eventually an on we'll make some
mistakes Magnus Carlsen will capitalize
and we'll start to see some wins
actually think that's why some of these
games Magnus Carlsen is going down to
you know the 64th move not necessarily
to win the game but to kind of grind
down his opponent try to take some
energy away from his opponent for later
games down the road so I'm definitely
hopeful watching this game that we're
gonna get to see some fireworks later on
so hopefully you guys enjoyed Game four
again we're tied up for draws to four
draws but looking forward to some
exciting games in the future thanks for
watching